you
hello and welcome from the royal swedish
academy of sciences i'm here with
ingomar Lindstrom and we're here to talk
about this year's Nobel Prize for
Physics vessel Lindstrom thank you very
much for for joining us here so soon
after he announces be made could we
begin by saying who's actually been
awarded this year's Nobel Prize of
physics yes there are two horses run
from France about habit and the one
person from Germany it's a pathetic game
back and water supplies being awarded
for this year it's voted for discovery
of a phenomena called giant
magnetoresistance which is due to the
behavior of electrons in magnetic
materials and you can use the fact that
electrons can have magnetic movements
parallel or antiparallel to an external
applied magnetic field and the electrons
with different spin directions they also
have a different resistances now that
might sound very technical to non
physicists but in fact people all around
the world be very familiar with how this
is being applied could you say how this
is being used I think the important
thing is that it's an effect which we
all know about because this is the
effect which is used in the reading
heads in the whole disk drives and which
has enabled the possibility to
miniaturize magnetic data recording
which we can all see in in the sciences
for the laptops we have today compared
to to say the computers in the in the
beginning of the 60s also so this
technology allows us to store
information along on things like
computer disks could you sort of give an
idea of how this is improve the way we
can store information or computers well
I'm sorry already decided if you've been
able to miniaturize the disk but they've
also been able to develop reading heads
which can detect much smaller magnetic
changes which in itself means that we
can make things smaller and smaller so
there are actually two very important
effects is phenomenal self and the fact
that the further development of the
phenomena has made it possible to make
the miniaturization go further
and in terms of miniaturization exactly
how much information is now allowed to
be it stored on discs as a result of
this technology well I I should should
remember the DD nice gross we actually
saw today but I think think that it's
sort of a hundred or thousand falls
compared to say ten years ago when when
this this technology was first utilized
it was discovered that by the end of the
80s but I think the first the first real
applications came 1997 or thereabout and
so what were the key discoveries from
the new laureates me what were their
Eureka moments in terms of creating or
discovering this technology well what
they realized was that by making this
layer three layer device with two
magnetic layers separated with a non
magnetic layer they could make use of
the fact that we conducted the
resistance due to the to spin directions
I talked about in the beginning are
quite different and by in this
arrangement and could make make actually
control the ddd total resistance with
three layer structure and so as I said
well I should also say that they were
also very clear on the phenomena as such
they really understood what they had
discovered and because similar effects
had been seen before by but people
didn't realize what they were looking at
at that time and worthy with these
single discoveries or what these are
serious discoveries every years I think
that you can actually say that these are
a single discoveries made independently
of the 22 allora teas and so it was a
real discovering and so what would the
individual discoveries that they made
about that overlapping with
commonalities actually they were
probably panko site was the same
discovery made at the same time because
the two publications which very ward is
Otis I came almost at the same time and
they were totally independent and what
this Lao research do what is what did
their discoveries allow researchers to
do Oh Dave okay what they
along now actually the development of a
completely new field the field which is
called spintronics where you combine the
said short properties and the magnetic
properties of electrons to make a
completely new type of devices which
will let Drive Amy notarized ation even
further I think so what does the future
hold for this field I think it quite a
lot it will be as a saint new type of
over devices based on what we call
spintronics it will be new types of a
magnetic memories based on on this
discovery think you call them for a
nonvolatile magnetic random access
memories which can be made with very
very high storage capacity and I also
think that what they've already started
to see your sensors magnetic sensors
which will be utilized in in in course
to measure position angle speed and so
on on different port in the car so the
feds say this is one of the first major
applications of nanotechnology the the
major the first major application is of
course the magnetic reading heads which
came already 1997 and as I already said
that the discover have now created new
and you completely new field with with
many new applications to come which we
haven't seen yet and you've ordered the
prize to two lorries now course you
could have gone to a maximum of three I
mean what was it the clear-cut decision
to give it to these two particular
researchers yes it was because since we
have already phenomena giant
magnetoresistance is clear that these
two persons already two persons behind
that discovery and what would the
reaction of the laureus just to end this
conversation well I is I understand they
were both very pleased of course and
really touched about getting the price
on the other hand I think you both of
them have got many other international
prices so I perhaps somewhere in the
mind stay they were thinking that
perhaps sometime we will also get into
Bell price so what's the total surprise
it's difficult to say but I think that
they were quite touched and as far as
you can tell from listening to what they
they said in the phone now wonderful
thank you very much for that veselin
strumming you can find out more about
this year's physics prize at
nobelprize.org the official website for
the Nobel foundation but now from now at
Stockholm goodbye